[Music]
what does it mean to be a skeptic while
it often means being critical of dubious
claims like miracle cures and fat diets
it can also refer to the philosophical
belief that some knowledge just can't be
attained
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives five
experts discuss these different types of
skepticism and surprisingly enough where
they meet we begin now by exploring the
definition of the philosophy of
skepticism
[Music]
the word skepticism derives from the
ancient greek word skepticos which means
questioning or doubting
many skeptical arguments are natural
everyday affairs like when you question
someone's evidence for a particular
opinion about sports or art or politics
philosophical skeptical arguments are
related to those everyday forms of
skepticism
but where those everyday expressions of
skepticism are particular concerning a
specific piece of evidence for an
individual claim
philosophical skeptical arguments tend
to be more general
philosophical skeptical arguments attack
a whole type of evidence like perceptual
evidence or inductive evidence or the
evidence of testimony
generally what such arguments suggest is
that the evidence in question isn't good
enough to give us knowledge so for
example skepticism about sense
perception suggests that the senses fool
us into thinking they are providing us
with evidence about the world around us
in reality the skeptic suggests what the
senses offer us is only a false promise
the evidence that the census provide is
in fact not sufficient to support
knowledge of the world that sense
experience seems to describe
the other types of skepticism work
similarly so whether you're dealing with
skepticism about the existence of other
minds or the existence of god the nature
of skeptical arguments is really to
question whether the evidence available
is sufficient to support knowledge or
belief
is there anything more intimate or
internal than pain descartes asks
he continues
and yet i have learned from some persons
whose arms or legs have been cut off
that they sometimes seem to feel pain in
the part which had been amputated
which made me think that i could not be
quite certain that it was a certain
member which pained me
even though i felt pain in it
it seems i can be wrong even about my
own body indeed descartes thinks that i
can ultimately be wrong in thinking that
i have a body
his acid test for certainty is the
hypothesis of an evil demon
suppose there is some immensely powerful
being who seeks to deceive me
i may think that certain events occurred
but the evil demon has planted false
beliefs in my mind
the evil demon leads me to think i see
something on the horizon but he's
planting false perceptions
i think i can manipulate two hands and
two legs but the evil demon is deceiving
me into thinking that i sense an act
with a body very different from the body
i actually have
perhaps the evil demon is deceiving me
into thinking that i'm the kind of being
that has a body at all
you see how devastating descartes acid
test is
only something that would survive the
hypothesis of an immensely powerful
deceiver can be accepted as absolutely
certain
can anything survive such a test
descarte thinks the answer is yes
dive directly into the depths of
skepticism and you will find a rock of
sheer certainty
descartes thinks he has found that rock
cochito ergosum
i think therefore i am
now descarte was a rationalist he
thought some beliefs can be justified a
priori justified without or before
having any sense experience
conversely the empiricist maintains that
we can't know anything without sense
experience so not only is it the best
way to gain knowledge it is the only way
the first major empiricist was the
british philosopher
john locke who in his 1689 book an essay
concerning human understanding suggested
that we are born tabula rossa as a blank
slate when we are born our minds contain
no ideas and we only start to form ideas
once we have sense experience
now by idea loc doesn't just mean a
revelation like i have an idea let's go
get some thai food
although that would count as an idea for
lock an idea is anything in the mind
beliefs sensations private thoughts
mental talking etc
according to locke we get ideas in two
different ways
by sensation observing the world and
reflection observing our own mental
operations
the former generates simple ideas like
heat and solidity shape and taste
the latter generates ideas of perception
doubting and reasoning we can combine
these ideas to come up with new unique
complex ideas
but we can't generate new simple ideas
on our own so ultimately everything in
our mind according to locke traces back
to something we learned through our
senses
so
since knowledge is justified true belief
and truth is correspondence with the
world if we want to know how accurate
our knowledge is we need to know whether
the ideas in our minds correspond to the
way the world is
to put it in lockheed terms we want to
know whether the idea in our minds
resemble the properties or qualities in
objects that produce those ideas
if we're simply looking for knowledge of
the phenomenal world the world of our
experience then most of the time our
experience will do and that is useful
knowledge to have given that we
primarily live in the phenomenal world
but we still need to realize that our
perceptions can lead us astray and we
never want to fool ourselves into
thinking that experience represents the
way the world actually is
for the most accurate knowledge of the
way the world is we need to rely on
science aka natural philosophy
scientists and social scientists in
particular have identified two ways for
a theory to be valid
internal validity
and external validity
internal validity means that a theory
has successfully established a
relationship between a cause and an
effect
with regard to internal validity most
scientific research is conducted to test
causal relationships
does a cause be does smoking cause lung
cancer
does an increase in advertising cause an
increase in sales
does a low carb diet cause weight loss
the other type of validity that
scientists must concern themselves with
is external validity
external validity refers to the
generalizability of the findings
how broadly can these findings be
applied
are they limited to situations very
similar to the ones in which they were
tested
if you are in the business of developing
theories
it's more important for the theory to be
correct
than for it to be generalizable
ideally of course you would like both
but if you had to pick
now i'm spending some time talking about
this up front because i believe that it
is important for you as a consumer of
research on human decision making to
critique that research in a responsible
and useful way
i am absolutely going to encourage you
to be skeptical of all of the research
findings i will tell you about
being skeptical makes you a good
scientist
and a good consumer of science you
should always be skeptical
a 2017 headline from cleveland's fox 8
read
two-thirds of popular baby food products
test positive for arsenic other toxins
the story said that quote according to a
report released this week two-thirds of
baby food products in the united states
test positive for arsenic and other
toxins
in the next paragraph quote the study
was conducted over a period of five
months by the clean label project and
included samples from 500 infant
formulas and baby food products from 60
brands
the usa today provided very similar
alarming text about the number of
products that were implicated unlike
most of the other media outlets they
also mentioned that these findings were
not published in a peer-reviewed journal
that was the first tip off here the
entire story was driven by essentially a
press release a document released to a
large number of media outlets in this
case by a non-profit organization called
the clean label project
this same organization had released a
similar report about what they
characterized as contaminants in pet
foods
and actually on their website some of
the verbiage about their pet food report
was copied verbatim into their material
about baby food
the source of a health story is
important and it's one of the first
things you should look for when you're
reading a story consider this the first
and most important tool in your skeptics
toolkit ask yourself what's the source
traditional dependable scientific
studies are published in what are called
peer-reviewed journals including many
you've heard of the new england journal
of medicine or the journal of the
american medical association
peer-reviewed means that every
publication has been vetted or reviewed
for accuracy by peers in this case other
physicians and scientists in the field
this doesn't guarantee that the study is
perfect but it's an important step and
at least one way that legitimate
journals try to make sure that what
they're publishing is reliable and
accurate
journals also employ editorial staff and
statisticians for additional review
the system isn't perfect but it's far
better than accepting every press
release as gospel
every story about this baby food
contamination issue should have made
clear that the findings weren't from an
accredited university or government
agency and were based on a non-published
non-peer-reviewed
press release make sure you think about
that when you're reading health stories
what is the source and am i sure that
it's credible
or better yet expect more than one
source for most health stories not just
the scientists who perhaps authored a
new paper but viewpoints from other
experts and i mean genuine experts in
the field
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here